- Now it's time for
tonight's #HashtagWars.
(audience cheering and applause)
(dinging)
Paul Scheer.
- Unbeatable at Studio 60
On The Sunset Strip trivia.
(audience laughing)
- Jesus Christ.
Wow, that was a reach
but I'll give you points.
(dinging)
Yeah, John.
- Speed alcohol poisoning.
(audience cheering and applause)
- Yeah it was.
(dinging)
Point Paul.
- Mastering a Slinky.
(laughing)
- Oh what a wonderful toy, points.
(dinging)
Nick.
- Debunking the documentary
Miss Congeniality.
(audience cheering and applause)
- Yes!
Oh no, that wasn't a documentary.
That was a totally fictional,
(dinging)
okay points, John.
- Christianity.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- Kevin.
- The Pabst.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, okay good nice.
(dinging)
You got it, yeah, Jen.
- Cat eye glasses woman.
(audience laughing)
- Okay yeah, yeah, I like it.
(dinging)
- Justin, Justin!
- The Farmer's Marketeer.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, good, points.
(audience applauding)
Good job.
- [Justin] And it comes on Sundays.
- [Chris] Justin.
- The Silver Lake Surfer.
(audience cheering)
- Yes, points!
(dinging)
Yes, Kevin.
- I'm going to go with Mumford
and Red Sons of Krypton.
(audience cheering)
- Okay, good, points.
(dinging)
Kevin.
- Spider, comma, man.
(audience laughing)
- Yes.
(dinging)
Points, Justin.
- The Barista!
(audience laughing)
- Yes!
(dinging)
Points Jen.
- I don't own an iron, man.
(buzzing)
- [Chris] God damn it!
(dinging)
- Yes, Beth.
- Abraham LinkedIn.
(audience laughing)
- Oh, oh god, yes.
Please stop sending me
requests for that, LinkedIn.
(dinging)
Adam.
- Will I Am McKinley.
(audience cheering)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Nate.
- Alright, Chester B. Arthur.
- Yes, Chester B. Arthur
yes, wonderful, points.
I think that would make it
better but I'll allow it,
(dinging)
Beth.
- Woodrow Wilson Phillips.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Nate.
- Martin Windowless Van Buren.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Beth.
- John Effing Kennedy.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah, nice, points.
(dinging)
Nate.
- Eleanor Roosevelt.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
Points.
(dinging)
Well played, Nate.
- Gerald Ford Focus.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
- Adam.
- William Howard Taft Mac N' Cheese.
(buzzing)
- Okay good, points!
(dinging)
Tom Rhodes.
- Teenage Mutiny Ninja Turtles.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, good one, points.
(dinging)
Ali.
- E Arr!
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, point.
(dinging)
Tom.
- The plunder years.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Good one, Neal.
- Law And Order SV Arr.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Ali.
- How I Met Your Wench.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Tom.
- Dancing With The Peg Legs.
(audience laughing)
- Yes.
(dinging)
Points, Neal.
- The Parr-tridge Family.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, points.
(dinging)
Tom.
- Scurvy Your Enthusiasm.
(audience cheering)
- Perfect, points.
(dinging)
Staring Larr-y David.
(audience laughing)
Neal Brennan.
- Inside Amy Schumer.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- Tom.
- It's Always Sunny In Somalia.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Ali.
- My So-Called Pirate's Life For Me.
- Yes, points.
Oh good one, yeah.
(dinging)
Neal.
- Game of Thrones but
I download it illegally
off of Pirate's Bay.
(buzzing)
- Yes, points, perfect!